okay so Rick and Morty season six
episode eight is now out and throughout
this video we're gonna be recapping the
entry breaking down the Easter eggs and
also giving our thoughts on it full
spoilers a heads up you haven't had a
chance to check it out then I highly
recommend that you check out now please
smash the Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy
the video and don't forget to subscribe
for breakdowns on the series every week
by the way huge thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
[Music]
the episode is called analyze paper this
is of course playing on the movie
Analyze This starring Billy Crystal and
Robert De Niro the episode of course
features Master two so it's a sort of
combination of his arrival and also that
movie that follow the gangster going to
a psychiatrist in this episode very much
centers around Rick analyzing why he
attracts so many stupid villains this is
seen from the offset with Rick and Morty
doing battle with the forces of Mr
Nimbus Nimbus appeared back in season
five during the episode more dinner Rick
Andre and it was said that he was a
nemesis of Rick though this was his
first appearance we were told that they
had a long-standing history in which the
pair were ones friends but this devolved
over time he was of course mentioned
last week with story Lord who brought up
that he wanted to become the new version
of him Nimbus is clearly based on Namor
or or is it Namo these days but but
either way the sexy costumes are pretty
similar as is the slickback hair that
the character has in the comics Neymar
is a bit of an anti-hero over at Marvel
and some of the nimbusin Rick he's had
an uneasy alliance with the good guys
he's went to war with wakanda a couple
of times and even ended up leaving the
Illuminati because he disagreed so
heavily with them the illumawati what
about the Dust always settles and he
retreats to the ocean much like what we
see with Nimbus Aquaman of course shares
similarities too and they're constantly
going back and forth with the people of
the surface World both Neymar and
Aquaman's brother Rome have attacked the
surface from time to time and they've
used sea life like what we see here Modi
bursts out a minigun and we can see that
he's actually firing lateral shells at
them instead of just shells you know
like shells like bullets and then this
demands that he destroys his surface
World base but Rick punches him into an
evergrey's oil tanker this spills into
the ocean prob probably destroying lots
of marine life there we're sorry nimbers
can walk on water and he also rides a
tidal way before strangling Rick with an
eel left with little options Rick sets
the base to self-destruct and this
explosion then implodes right in on
itself this reminded me a lot of the end
of poltergeist and keeping in line with
the Marvel stuff it's also similar what
hang Pym does at the end of Ant-Man
Nimbus returns to his giant clam shell
which is also what he arrived in during
the first episode oh what you doing mate
I am Mr nimus whatever come on Morty at
this point cookie Magneto shows up and
no prices for guessing that he's based
on Magneto guy can control everything we
call a cookie but I don't know whether
this is like dough or sugar because
because that's a lot of stuff you could
rip someone apart if you can control
sugar anyway we don't get to find out as
he's melted and Rick says looking down
but I can't fight another one of these
90s style goofball super villains I'm
not the [ __ ] tick clear reference to
the superhero The Tick Who start off in
the comics before getting his own Amazon
show he's also had cartoons as well and
I know you're going to write that in the
comments yeah just just lay off it
anyway anyway at this point Morty brings
up the fact that these people seeking
recount might be for a reason Batman
comics especially have been filled with
the idea that he creates his own
villains and this has been reflected in
a number of different superheroes the
theory states that insane people see
Batman doing theatrical things and they
realize that they themselves condone
costumes and create personas they are
attracted to Batman as they very much
view him as an opposite to them that
they're obsessed with at the point that
they completely hate him this is sort of
the case here with Rick attracting all
these weird villains who want to take
him down next we see Mr Calypso which
I'm guessing he's called that cause Mr
Mitchell plix is really hard to
pronounce Mr Mr
Mr maximum Mr Mixels talk
mixer petal my name is
sis was a Superman villain who is a
fifth dimensional imp that's basically a
sort of trickster he can warp and bend
reality to his whim and he torments
soups throughout a lot of comics that he
features in ones Rick actually listens
to Morty and decides to analyze why he
attracts so many strange villains anyway
that takes us into the title sequence
let's watch some crazy stuff yo this
video is sponsored by whiskey eye drops
put a bit of whiskey in your eye ah
Rick oh my God this video is sponsored
by wrong prescription I thought this was
a commercial what's going on I mean
don't don't worry about it just see
where this goes the wrong prescription
because for sponsoring this video oh my
God it's still the commercial
now from here we cut to Rick at Dr
Wong's debuting all the way back in the
pickle Rick episode she made a point not
to judge when he stumbled into her
office he belittled the entire
Psychiatry profession and we can see
that mirrored here with him refusing to
sit down he just doesn't take it
seriously and wants to know why there's
a Target on his back we see Calypso is
stuck in some kind of torture device and
Rick also says you don't shoot Batman in
his Batman logo this is a reference to
The Dark Knight Returns and in that we
discovered that Batman had highly
reinforced Kevlar behind the bat symbol
so that when people shot at the
brightest thing on his chest they
wouldn't actually hurt him Calypso also
seems like he got his life force trained
out of him and it might be giving an
artist Superman after the nuke in that
probably a reach but either way Wong's
advice is to just ignore the villains in
this entire episode sort of works as a
metaphor for internet Fame I think
people think that it's straightforward
and that when you blow up it's all likes
and retweets but the public can turn on
people really easily and completely ruin
their lives shout outs to metal riddle
dude on Reddit for saying that the whole
episode's basically a comment on how
everyone wants to Trend until they're
trending this is mirrored in both Rick
and Jerry with one taking the back seat
whilst the other one shoots to fame the
user said that Rick taking Master's
Place could also show that we don't
really see the full story on things we
just read the headlines More's a pretty
sure that Dan Harmon doesn't have
Twitter and this episode could be a
metaphor for him explaining why he
doesn't want that kind of attention go
back home to the family congratulating
Rick for taking therapy seriously also
kind of feel like the series in general
plays up the idea that therapy is a good
thing and the entire episode does sort
of cement that and the piece is ruined
by Master a villain who sprays urine on
absolutely everything I can't be
bothered to keep beeping his name so I'm
just gonna call him we master or urine
master or something but but YouTube yet
they've been demonetizing my videos
recently so just gotta keep the Friendly
Kitty stuff like like a man who sprays
on everything now his design is of
course based on the Green Goblin with a
villain standing on top of a glider he
also has a helmet with a breathing mask
in it and is that is that we surrounding
his face never mind now after insulting
summer and ruining his flowers Jerry
goes outside and has a cat fight with
him during this we get a cameo by the
neighbor Gene who's popped up throughout
the series similar to Wong the original
version we make are Cronenberg when the
initial Universe did that and he also
died when Mr funnels took over the
second Universe earlier in the season
during night family Jerry gets it by
hand and we dude and he flees in staying
tears whilst Jerry gains Fame and
notoriety I love how he Quivers away
from the kiss Victory because his lips
are burst up and it just kind of shows
how much of a wimp he is he beat him
with a garden Flamingo ornament and
eventually gets labeled Flamingo dad by
his adoring fans the next day at
breakfast we see them eating some
strawberry smiggles which are of course
based on Lucky Charms outside the
intergalactic Council of Heroes arrives
but rather wanting Rick they just want
Jerry they present him with a sticky orb
and we learn that they're in charge of
protecting peace and order in the Galaxy
clearly based on the Green Lanterns
they're orbs much like Rings bond with
people that have a pure heart Rick is
banned from them and also the next door
app and though this storyline should be
something that takes his full attention
he's happy to let Jerry take it rick
gives him a mech suit so he can fight
space Hitlers I'm sure the eagle-eyed
viewers amongst you have probably
recognized this from the new opening
credits he flies off similar to Iron Man
and goes to destroy the Legion of
Hitlers who are based on their own super
villains this is being led by a
character based on Mr mine from Shazam
and you can actually see the symbol on
his chest has Hitler's side parting with
a little Tash that they all carry
there's also a parody of Gorilla Grodd
The Riddler and an actual Hitler who
probably comes from a universe where he
lived like man in the High Castle or
that movie for the land where Germany
won World War II he blows up the planet
but we learn that no one other the
Hitlers were actually on it this is a
comment on recent superhero movies out
of major state that no civilians are in
areas where there are fights happening
because everyone lost their Overman of
Steel the headline also says finally a
cool dad and this is probably making fun
of how dads are depicted as complete
idiots in most fiction and adverts he
goes viral fighting fly aliens and we
see a little coming from Summer saying
that's my dad we can also see that the
cat's squanchy is in the comments too
and I though it's a little Cameo it's
nice to see him pop-up the armor is also
kind of like Hal Jordan's Parallax suit
and it's also mixed with a bit of Mega
Man as well Jerry's got a ton of adoring
fans and wall-to-wall coverage on TV
Rick travels to Dr Wong's and we see Mr
Golden fold in a session with her Rick
quickly turns him into a fly and this is
called back to when Jerry brought up how
Rick turned himself into a pickle and
the housefly to avoid therapy last time
he said it was just an ordinary fly but
with the gun here yeah you never bloody
no now we cures golden fold and we see
Jerry appearing in an mcus hologram
beating up a slice of toast and a
breakfast themed Universe I love how
there's a cut in the bottom of the toast
so he can walk we also see bacon Forks
pancakes and eggs around it the sun is
also an egg because it's sunny side up
I'm guessing the Morty butter thing from
the title sequence is also from this
universe Rick eventually realizes that
he's going in the right direction and we
see his Jerry is brought in to sell
Mitsubishi spaceships at the event Mr
spring Bean ambushes Rick and he stopped
by a whiplash parody in Dr buckles I
didn't see if there was any vegetable
themed supervillains but couldn't find
them however this guy is clearly based
on Whiplash now they end up fighting
each other whilst Rick ignores it and
realizes that he's out he turns to the
bottle low and still can't escape the
attention that Jerry's getting it's
kinda like a John Wick thing but like
Godfather 3 they pull him right back in
initially he does turn to the bottle but
he can't escape the attention that
cherries getting Rick decides to go
looking for Nintendo Wii player and we
sort of get a Watchman parody with Rick
entering his home this is a similar
setup to what molok had in the comic
book a movie and we saw that he lived in
a rundown apartment by himself turns out
P master has ended his own life in a
bathtub which might be full of pee and
though Rick revives him he sees that
he's too far gone and he has to kill him
the scene in the bathtub is kind of
similar to the one in eight namely how
Stan does it and we also saw this used
in The Godfather Part 2. Rick goes to
leave but number one Master's daughter
shows up and thus he ends up donning his
helmet in order to save her the pain of
losing her father he finds it out from
him and the episode switches up a gear
with Rick deciding to become the villain
so that he can prove to people he wasn't
a complete failure he doesn't want to
live this life forever though so he does
start to put things in place so that the
guy can basically go out a hero he
hammers away a new costume and this of
course has a lot of similarities to Tony
Stark creating his first Iron Man Mark 1
armor in his first film love the little
eye shot scene and these are of course
in tons of superhero movies including
the Iron Man suit up he starts to save
the villain's reputations and saves a
cutout of a tree similar how Superman
did it in his first movie in the
background we hear the song Get Ready by
two unlimited and watch as he creates a
year and ice rink for a children's
hospital and also kills a Kaiju you're
in for a big surprise cause the pigs
can't miss and we see his people jump to
his side because he did something nice
across the Galaxy he starts saving
people and reveals his plan is to plan a
bomb in a city and then sacrifice
himself by flying it away clear not at
the end of The Dark Knight Rises in
which Batman flew the nuke out of the
city and we see a similar Council to
what the Owens have across the Galaxy
they want to give orb ship to P master
and he fits the mold of a reform Villain
Like Zemo or Captain cold cut it off in
city and Orphans of course lit a comic
books in general with several characters
having dead parents that drive them we
see an ad for a big John intro attorney
and also several people in suits to
protect them from the blast there's also
a nice little one for water the new milk
and Alley boxes the cardboard that won't
quit the news network is spelled to be
orphan and the presenter has a Dusty
worn jacket in hat like he's ripped
right out of Oliver Twist after it shows
up we see some shops including rags and
riches as well as orphan themed streets
called urchin Rowan Wayward there's also
please sir soup you'll want some more
please sir
I want some more and next to this is
Wayward yard clothing with a Little
Orphan hat sign and pretty much everyone
there is a stereotypical orphan Rick
gives them pops as well as Dear Me Now
Jerry arrives but his ego's got hurt too
much and he decides to stop Master he
sees Rick who then saves him but it does
enough to win the pride of Slash
Master's daughter she's so proud to see
him on TV and it's a scene that's popped
up in a lot of movies first time I
remember seeing it was an Armageddon and
there's also the end of the recent
suicide squad movie Jerry has turned to
heal and the council members show up and
take the orb back it has been powering
Jerry's suit like an arc reactor and
removing it causes the suit to fall
apart rather than letting Jerry know
that we Master ended his own life though
Rick takes the ball because that's what
Heroes do the series as a whole has been
filled with the idea that retcon change
but this episode especially has shown
that he in fact can there are several
inconsistencies with him actually being
the villain but the fan only take it at
face value they assume Rick let Jerry
beat him up so that he could feel more
confident but there are a couple of
little theories thrown offhand by the
group this includes that he might be a
robot or that he avatar'd it they
decided to be unworthy and it's all
under the bridge now Rick tells more
either truth and it makes the situation
way worse which makes them realize that
Fame isn't all it's cracked up to be
should just let people walk all over you
I guess and that takes us another
post-credit scene we see the council
going through the possible members and
this includes Jack Miller aka carjack we
learned that he lifted the car off a
woman which might be another 70s
Incredible Hulk in that we heard a story
about a woman who is triggered by stress
to the point she could lift a car in
order to save her son and this was then
studied to see how it could be applied
to day-to-day situations discard your
idea is shut down and finally they check
out Mr Nimbus they say he can control
the police and this is a call back to
him doing it in the first episode he
appeared in either way that ends the
entry and it was a pretty fun one that
also went pretty dark I don't think it
was in my top five for the season so far
but I did enjoy it and in all honesty
this season's been such a strong one
that's saying that isn't even really a
ding on it it's nice seeing Rick
actually grow and see what it's like for
his villains kind of deconstructs the
psychology of them and shows how even
the most ridiculous ones have their own
story and family lives so yeah it was
pretty good so like I did sound like I
was crapping on it there a bit but I I
did think it was good anyway enough of
me rambling let me know your thoughts on
the episode below and if there's
anything we missed then make sure you
drop it in the comments we're on a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of House of the Dragon
season one on the 15th of December and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe and notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we picked the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our writing of last week which will
be linked on screen right now you go
fully in on the episode talk about lots
of cool things in it so definitely head
over there if you haven't seen it by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been poor I'll see you next
time take care peace